[Music]
eleven-year-old Charlotte never as is
breaking racial barriers with her
impressive performance as Murray in the
Nutcracker
she is the first black young woman ever
to play that leading role in the New
York City Ballet's production former
ballet star Tony Williams has broken
barriers for more than half a century
his urban Nutcracker in Boston
incorporates dance styles from hip hop
to flamenco and Mexican folk more than
75 kids from different ethnic and
economic backgrounds are part of this
year's production it all supports the
mission diversity through dance the
first show it's like oh my god is this
going to you know fail but the applause
was just tremendous this holiday season
marks 19 years of Boston's urban
Nutcracker cast and crew as diverse as
the choreography and music you have
diversity and the dance styles diversity
and the music diversity in the cast on
the stage because we're a multiracial
multicultural cast and also in the
audience was that your intent or is that
how this has happened it was sort of a
dream it just happened the show's
creator Tony Williams became the Boston
ballets first african-american principal
dancer in the late 60s a driving force
in his desire to give opportunity to
underrepresented youth I started dance
late I was 16 but before that as a very
young kid I was in street gangs here in
Boston and getting into trouble so dance
sort of saved my life that's no little
thing that's true I some of the guys in
the gang I were but most of the guys are
dead or some went to jail so I was
really fortunate Jason Jordan a new
dancer in this year's show also
considers himself fortunate as a dancer
who comes from an urban neighborhood it
just made sense to me
it was like being home and since I was
trained classically it just molded it
together in a way that it felt really
natural for me
slow good boy Jordan teaches dance at a
Boston Public School in an underserved
community by recruiting some of his
students for the show he's given it new
flavor and his kids a new outlook what
have you found about bringing these kids
that maybe weren't exposed to dance
before into the fold here that's the
most important thing to me is having
these kids when they're done with me I
teach at a K through 8 when they're done
with eighth grade and they're beautiful
dancers where do they go now to have a
place yes and professional dancing it's
a place that didn't seem to exist for
Erika Lam when she was dancing as a
young girl in Boston Lam wasn't offered
the lead role of Clara in the Nutcracker
because she was black that's the first
time I realized that my skin color was
gonna be you know something I have to
think about you know if I wanted to do
ballet it was Boston in the late 70s
busing was going on racial tensions were
pretty much pretty high I mean but my
mom was brought into the director's
office and they said you know we love
your daughter she's very talented
but it's a period piece and this is
Boston and we just don't know really how
people are gonna react in this urban
rendition lamb is playing the role of
Clara's mother the stage ballet isn't
like 15th century aristocracy anymore
you know I mean anybody can do ballet
and you know and anybody could be a
family part of that family is a
wide-ranging group of young dancers show
of hands how many of you had seen the
classic Nutcracker before he started
doing urban Nutcracker every year my
parents would take well my mom and
grandma would take me to see the
Nutcracker
the Boston Ballet but then he came along
in my life
yeah so I see in his show I'm like mom I
got to do this it was just like
different for me and it made me want to
start doing it um my mom was like now
give me like hey do you want to do this
do you want to do the urban eye tracker
I was like I'll try it and I've been
here ever since
if you had to sum up in a couple words
what the experience of doing this show
is like for you what would you say
amazing incredible sharing that joy is
what makes it all worthwhile for Tony
Williams because of 3,000 people there
might be one little girl or one boy that
comes that is going to be transformed
and it's gonna save one life and that
the way it's saved your life yes yes yes
yeah and so that that's well that's why
I do it it's like I'm not a spring
chicken anymore and but it's the young
kids it's like how could I not do this
for them they look forward to it every
year and again almost 20 years of this
and in an effort for him to bring dance
to all kids there's a new program and a
dance apprenticeship that they're
launching in January and it will be for
kids who show promise but can't afford
high levels of dance training the goal
to have more professional dancers of
color I feel like we talked about this a
lot but it's the idea that when you see
somebody who looks like you doing
something suddenly you say I can do that
and especially with this and opening up
the styles of dance it's opened up the
minds to ballet because if you're
brought in by the tap or by flamenco and
then you see the ballet you may be
intrigued as well on that
I love Dana when Jason tells you that he
teaches kids and schools that are
underserved and that he gets them into
this program because it's one thing to
have a parent introduce you to George
Ballantine's the Nutcracker it's a night
here to have a teacher and bring you
along for the ride that's wonderful and
drink it almost goes back to the story
that you brought us earlier of what's
the next step so it's great that you
introduce them right but now how do they
take that next step and this is saying
yes this can be a career for you this
can be something that you think
about doing professional yeah I love it
love it great piece very well done
you